can you justify losing 900 pounds a
month that doesn't make any sense well
you know keep it on management company
and because there's someone in signing
leagues and in this video you're gonna
get some inside information on how to
speak to landlords how they think why on
earth would they pass you their house on
a rent to rent and what do you need to
say to them to get the deal some of my
viewers might recognize your face
because you passed the property on to me
it was a renter and in London and some
people have said why on earth would you
pass the property on to some guy that
you've literally just met that day why
did you pass your property as a rental
meant home to me that's the first
question um first of all I didn't know
you were doing a challenge and later I
saw it and I thought wow what's this guy
doing and and then later I understood
why why why like you were so keen on
showing the tenants around later on and
I thought wow this guy has a lot of
energy wants he wants to show me he can
do the management job already and I
liked you and liked your energy I guess
and I mean I do business with people
whose energy I like and where I get a
gut feeling I go ahead even if it's not
so logical sometimes I follow my feeling
it's something I've learned to do in
through various experiences and I guess
that answers your question is well why
did I fast my the keys on to you before
we even have had a contract I trusted
you and I felt like you I mean you
showed me with that viewing you showed
me that you could do what you are doing
watch what you said you could do yeah
[Music]
interesting you talked about energy
confidence trust things like that
because a lot of people think that
actually in order to do business you
need to have a really established agency
I didn't come to you as an established
estate agent
I came to choosing individual and you
actually told me later that you didn't
like working so much with big agencies
and you'd had some bad experiences is
that something you mind talking about a
little bit
yes so so you were you were one guy who
who I felt would be managing my property
and I thought okay I like this guy he
knows what he's doing he's also good
with people because I could see it and
you actually got one guy to agree in
front of me to rent it so fantastic can
represent already oh no with the
question wouldn't they just pass it on
to an agency why would they work with an
individual wants to have rent to rent
when they've got big established brands
it doesn't make any sense and that's
kind of the question I'm confronting
yeah okay so so there's frozen coins for
a to to having an agency and to having a
one-person show and I've tried both in
the past I've had one person run things
for me I've had agencies run things for
me when I had agencies everything was
professional and we had contracts but
usually the contracts were biased
against me as the customer so if there
were some damages I would have to pay
them and I would have to pay a surcharge
for a little thing like changing light
bulb would cost me sometimes I don't
know three hundred percent because of
the agency fees in addition to the cost
of the light bulb and the cost of the
visit so there there were some hidden
costs with agencies that I didn't like
that I experienced and I didn't like and
also when you deal with an agency
sometimes you see personally sometimes
you see person B and sometimes you see
person C because they MB are on leave so
you have to establish lots of
relationships but people and and because
I want a one I like to work with people
of course my my priorities is to have a
human human source of connection and
business not just working the numbers on
and I thought with you it would be I'm
just dealing with you you deal with my
tenants they're gonna be happy with you
and I'm gonna be happy with you and it
will be kind of backfired on me because
it's interesting because so many people
think
Lando's
big companies I came to you doing a
challenge not for real challenge on
camera secret cameras and I got the deal
but then once I've got the deal he found
out okay actually I'm gonna company and
I passed the deal on to one of my team
and I told you actually can you deal
with this person and and then you were
like hmm actually what happened after
that and how did that come about so I
wasn't so keen on sharing this because
like okay my honest truth is I wanted to
deal with you
because I liked your energy and I
thought okay let's go for it and and of
course we'll have a three month break
laws I think you mentioned that break
laws I didn't show in the video but you
mentioned I break laws and you said if
it doesn't work you or I can pull out
after three months and if it goes if we
like it then we'll we'll have a wiki
coin so I thought okay there is news for
three months worst case is I will lose
three months friend but actually we were
gonna pay two months in advance anyway
or something like so I I wasn't gonna be
risking too much and from my feeling it
was gonna work with you and then you
passed it on to someone in your team and
whoever that is he was busy and and
basically I wanted so usually I manage
my own properties myself I like it
and there's many pros in it for example
I have much more control over my
property if there is a concern like my
pump is broken or whatever I get to know
about it first it doesn't have to go
through someone and that someone might
be on holiday or might be not not up for
letting me know and and things might
build up whereas if if the tenant asks
me it might take me maybe 1 or 2 days to
fix it if it's not urgent or one or two
minutes to sort it out a bit surgeon but
there's less people and and there's
there's less of a chain yes but usually
I manage things myself
yeah but when I have an agency I guess
the one of the pros of having someone
manage it would be that I don't have to
deal with things like this and I just
got married and I had my honeymoon and I
thought okay let's try this let's let's
get this managed and as you know it was
advertised on spare room so I wanted to
manage it myself I wanted to rent it our
room by room it it had an HMO license
and I wanted to manage it so he
approached me to manage it for me I
already had some decision-making to do
because I I was planning to rented
myself and then when he came to
negotiated and I thought actually yeah
why not you will save me management time
I might I might earn less money but you
will save me some time and I can enjoy
my my honeymoon really interesting
because sometimes people think as a
one-man band
there was a sole entrepreneur without a
team without backing without a big
website and ground they think that they
are almost discriminated against it is
harder for them but actually this is the
opposite because when I came to you as
an individual it's me you were like oh
great I want to work your you bought
into me on that day you gave him your
went to rent deal which you were happy
with I was happy with but then when you
when it transpired that actually I'm a
millionaire I've got a big company I've
got a lot of staff and I said I'm not
gonna be with this so I don't want you
contacting me direct but it's my team is
this summe your oh man this is like a
big agency I don't really want this I'm
agile just pass it on to an estate agent
so you you wanted to buy into that sole
entrepreneur that one-man band that's
got a great personality a great energy
great confidence if you know is good you
know you can trust which is we backward
from what most people think which is
just crazy to me like that I mean why
would a landlord like you do a rent to
rent deal and receive a guaranteed rent
because you just said that you'd be
getting less money by passing on
similars rent to rent I told you at the
time I said I'm expecting to make my
eight nine hundred quid I think it was
from Emory a month from this and you
were like I don't care I just don't want
the hassle
talk to me about that yeah I mean we
went over it in the video I'm shocked
but happy
to discuss it again so I was gonna get
less money I advertise it for three
thousand six hundred as a whole or or
six hundred fifty per room I think so
minimum I was gonna make three nine so I
was gonna make nine hundred less at
least nine hundred less from from the
potential and so I was gonna make less
money but I was out with a million
properties but well how much you say you
were gonna be losing nine hundred for
sue Murray that means I would have been
Nathan not one can you justify losing
nine hundred pounds a month that doesn't
make any sense
management company and because there's
security in it so so first of all we had
three months to work it out you see to
see whether it would work or not
the property actually had some problems
later and I didn't know because it was a
new build but there was an infestation
of rats in the pipeline it wasn't even
in the house was the pipeline but they
were making scratching noises so I had
to deal with it and when I of course I
found out I was the manager I dealt with
it it was expensive
[Music]
now I had a few I had a few problems
even though it was a new build and I had
to deal with it and had I not pulled out
I would have had to pay for it probably
or at least we would have come to an
agreement but I wouldn't have had to
deal with like Bill there's people who
like I had builders I had pest control
people and the tenants of course were
we're not so happy with the situation
which is completely understandable and
of course even though I was abroad at
the time on some training I dealt with
it immediately they were happy and I'm
forever grateful for their patience but
but I had to deal with it basically and
if you were running it then you would
have had to deal with them just update
me now no no okay so I had no idea where
you were
I have we met since no so we met on that
day we didn't sign a contract but we did
get handshake so we got a handshake we
got the agreement it was sometime later
when the what transpired actually it
wasn't gonna be me my team and you were
like I'm really sorry to put you a
manatee words and you're a man of
integrity when you when you said to me
you know what I'm really actually I'm
thinking I'm gonna change my mind how
was I was did I make it difficult for
you was I was I do SH bag what happened
no I'll tell you the truth you were you
didn't respond on the on the day and
maybe not even on the next day and I
thought someone is so busy I doesn't
mean that he's he's not gonna change
he's not gonna accept my change of mind
but actually he was just busy and and
later you got in touch with me and said
no problem worse place and the keys an
assignment
and you said it's okay I appreciate you
that's what you said and I don't know
right now what a gentleman and really I
thought was a gentleman you know what
though you know someone's carats if I
have my anything's if you leave a job or
leave a workplace or come out of
contracts and it really and you make it
difficult and you're awkward at the end
that's someone's true character and I
think it really pays even if you think
okay this deal is not going to go ahead
so just to just be nice and to be
reasonable rather saying but you agreed
this or you and be difficult because you
never know when you're going to run into
that person again and you never know
when you might end up doing a YouTube
video with that person again
over over zoom you know zrinko
reasonable you know and I think we were
reasonable would you consider now what's
your thoughts on rent to rent now
because that would have been I believe
your first Frenchman do you still think
renter it's good do you think there's
you think it's good for the rent to rent
to do the it's good for the land what's
your view on bread to rent from the
whole experience from everything that
you've learned since and so I only
manage my portfolio because I don't
really I don't really have time for
other things and if anything I would
offload some of my my properties to get
more time to manage our projects and I
think I even said this in the in the
video it was going to be my first renter
and the first property I would keep out
so that I have time for other projects
and other projects I also meant marriage
I guess I I didn't say it I didn't feel
I needed to share it in the video but
this was one of my my projects in the
pipeline honeymoon um I think rent rent
can work because okay why it can work
because okay it's very similar to giving
a property to an agent and actually your
question is from a perspective of a
landlord or from the perspective of from
a web services perspective so when I'm
teaching people about rents around Simon
on doing measurements I know what's need
to make I'm gonna give you a guaranteed
rent and then I'm gonna rent it out or
the room I'm going to keep the profit so
as long as I get the right property to
get the right price and you go show
right you're gonna get some cash flow
now albeit you can have to manage the
property you're gonna
to work it's not going to be passive but
it's kick if you play someone's income
and it could get them started in
property they didn't have a lot of money
so that's what's any for them
my question to you is what do you think
that is a good offer to a landlord geez
are their landlords cuz people say to me
are no landlord would do it no reason
I'm happy to interview you because
you're a landlord that's willing you
wanted to do it and I know if I said to
you hey I'll personally manage it you'd
be like do it you just don't be like
this whole idea of working with like a
corporate team or or or you know
faceless company with different staff
and different than you took me someone
different every time I get that but I'm
just trying to understand like how do
people approach a landlord to get a rent
to rent deal how do they do that
what's in it for the landlord as a
landlord I would want a renter enter to
offer me a clear agreement that includes
what would happen when problems call
when problems happen when things go
wrong so who would be responsible for
dealing with problems would there be a
floating budgets and to to to solve
problems and who would pay for the
repairs what kind of repairs with the
landlord's have to pay and what would
the renter enter pay for things like
who'd pay the cost of cost of rubbish
collection if there is big items to to
be carried away like if a bed is broken
who would pay for their removal for
example would it be their enter enter
from their profits or would it be
landlord because if because if the
landlord will have to pay lots of things
then they're not getting a guaranteed
rent of three thousand thirteen because
they're having to pay lots of things
every month and so the guarantee needs
to be like strong yeah and also would
you offer a look nice the break calls
helped you a lot as well do it either
you know this is this is a three or five
year contract but if it's not working
and if I'm not paying you on time and if
I'm difficult and if the tenants it's
like trashing the property and it's not
then you know that after three months
you can even fire me and if I've broken
my contract and if I'm not doing what
I've said I'm going to do the way I said
I was going to do it you can just take
the property back and I'm actually going
to be liable for any problems or issues
or mess that seemed to read
I did the whole we negotiate for a long
time back and forth and I play the whole
thing on the on the on YouTube because
it was it would have been too long but
this whole break clause thing I think so
important because if you're going into a
rental rent if you set up a break laws
right with the right terms and
conditions not only does it protect the
landlord's like you and that gave you
comfort but it also gives comfort to the
renter renter because if the landlord
after three weeks goes actually thanks
for putting all these tenants in thanks
for making the property nice you know
what you're fired
depending on who who tries to terminate
the contract you need to make sure that
both parties are looked after and you've
got something in writing or something
clips they know what's going to be out
pocket yeah
okay so so as a general principle it's
very important that you're not just
doing business to earn something you
also need to make sure it's a win-win
yes that it's a principle which is which
is which if you go in it for yourself
then you're gonna do business one time
but if if you take care of clients like
what you did you send me the keys
immediately then I know that next time
if I have someone asking me who do I ask
for enter and and say this guy came
approached me I withdrew but actually
was really gentleman and I think he's a
good guy to work with and I would
recommend you to this guy even though
right more to show and then maybe five
other people would come to me and I
would recommend them I recommend you to
them as well so so when when you act in
a in a decent way with people then they
will they will remember it yeah and I
guess what why am I saying this it's
because when you're renting to rent and
you should really be mindful of the
landlord's concerns because because I
mean it doesn't show really in the video
because it was cut of course but but I
asked you lots of questions and you gave
me lots of assurances and as to how you
would take care of the property and what
what what I can do with things go wrong
if things went wrong yeah but it's funny
as well because I really believe that
the reason I was able to win over this
deal and the reason I can win a lot of
deals it's and the point I was trying to
prove in doing this video in the
first place when I went to London is
that any body regardless of your
experience and backgrounds and wealth
anybody can go out and hustle and with
the right knowledge and the right and
the right business confidence and the
right ability to be able to come up with
win-win deals anybody can go and secure
a rent around and fair enough like that
this this particular deal that we did
after a few days when you realized who I
was and how that was to be a bit
different what you thought if I was an
individual you know we decided that
actually this wasn't the best deal but
the actual ability to go out and secure
landlords so this is funny because I met
I didn't just meet you on that day
agents and as a result of that I've gone
on to do other deals
I met agents that will give you enter
answers it's so doable and I did not on
that day go and show off about odd this
is my experience this is mine I just
went from scratch with the knowledge and
the confidence and the ability to strike
a deal and I think that was the point of
the video and that was the reason why I
did it was it was to show what's
possible and to kind of try my best to
eliminate excuses from people who say I
can't do it because I've not got much
money or I've not got much I've got a
proper company move staff or I've not
got a good reputation yet that was the
reason I did it of course of course my
two cents is that you were lucky on that
day because you met how many how many
landlords I spoke to probably about
twenty I went and saw maybe seven and I
okay cuz you filmed it you filmed how
many beautiful I think you've been this
video walking cold into a spy agencies
and letting agents and they're shaking
my hand at the end saying yes we'll pass
you went to rent deals scratch yeah so I
guess I was gonna say you were lucky
that that on the first day you met you
met you had a good deal yeah a handshake
and even though later I didn't my mind
but the better you get and the more you
practice the luckier you get of
of course but you awkward you are
correct what why is it taking me so long
to get you on the channel that's what
sorry I owe you I owe you an apology and
you know this and one of your team got
in touch with me and and I ignored it
because I didn't recognize their name
and I didn't even open their email yeah
I was too busy since that day but the
thing is you coming on this channel
there's nothing in it for you you've
come on just giving you time voluntary
to share from a landlord's experience
how to help so I really value coming on
and sharing from the position of a
landlord I really really really value
that and I hope that this message gets
out there and touches people inspires
people and also it gives people the
ability to be able to be a professional
that comes with true win-win deals thank
you you know it there's more I want to
say because when I when I wanted to say
you were lucky I guess for me it's
important to make it clear that when I
started out in property I had to
approach many many many many many
different people in order to secure a
really good I buy properties below
market value I had to try like I had to
view like 200 properties before I found
a really good and so that's why I ask
you how many landlords you met on the
day because because it takes time it
takes a lot of practice and actually its
property is in some ways it's hard work
when when you're really good at it it
becomes easy but it takes my take not it
might not take lots of time but it might
take a lot of energy and focus so so
properties is hard and easy at the same
time just pick up the phone three times
the name strike a deal you're gonna have
it you're gonna have to speak to more
people more people more people again and
again and then even when you do strike a
deal things fall out of bed like
literally probably 70% of property deals
where I put an offer analyst accepted
70% of them probably fall out a bet or
at some point so and you need to
discipline your disappointment when that
happens and just keep going and follow
the process and you have landlords like
me who later change their mind and drop
out and and you have to decide do I and
force this or do I not and if you don't
then you lose out on the deal I feel
like you did on the deal literally just
call you and it was a deal what was
going through and the can you come back
in a few months because I just want to
reassess my options now my my job is to
just let her off the hook
give her a get out of jail card and be
really easy on it because then in in
three weeks time if she thinks actually
I do want to sell it again she's gonna
come back to me because I made her life
easy I put pressure on her and say not
only you need to say to me you need said
to me she's not gonna she's not gonna
tell it to me she's just gonna feel bad
feel awkward and then never want to
speak to me for a bit
of course we're dealing with humans and
[Music]
those BNP deals you know you got my
number man give me a shout give me a
corner I wish you all the very best
cheers man likewise it's all the best
hopefully that's giving you a little bit
of an idea about what a landlord thinks
about rents or rents and now when you go
and approach landlords you have an idea
about where they're coming from top of
them a win/win rent to read deal it's
going to give you cash flow that's going
to give them an easy life what about
when you're approaching agents though
and you're approaching election agencies
well as you've seen on my financial
freedom challenges I've secured rent to
rent from scratch with letting agencies
so if you haven't seen the interview of
me and Ellen I would highly suggest you
check that interview out I'll give you a
little sneak preview now but click on a
link for more check it out subscribe
like the channel enjoy secured for me
from the landlord what was it about I
familiar about the situation what make
look that made you confident